[Music]
hello and welcome to the take with
sophie ridge live at nine here in the
heart of westminster well british
politics is known for being brutal when
your time's up in number 10 the removal
vans turn up and the next prime minister
arrives shortly after we're not quite at
that point yet but today really summed
up the huge change about to take place
boris johnson faced his last prime
minister's questions leaving by saying
it was mission largely accomplished and
a few hours ago we found out who will
replace him in just over six weeks time
therefore rishi sunak and liz truss
will be the candidates going forward to
a final ballast of conservative party
members
so it's rishi sunak vs liz trust now
conservative party members will decide
which one becomes our next prime
minister at the start of september
who is the best person to defeat
kirstama in the labour party at the next
election i believe i'm the only
candidate who can do that
well the former chancellor topped the
final ballot with 130 337 votes from his
colleagues followed by liz trust foreign
secretary on 113.
i can hit the ground running and i can
get things done and i think that's what
colleagues have voted for and that's
what i now want to take to conservative
members around the country
well meanwhile a few hours before we got
that leadership contest result the
current prime minister was ending his
very last prime minister's questions i
want to thank everybody here and
so the changing of the guard at the top
of british politics and government is
well underway we'll try and find out
what conservatives voters think of the
choice the party now faces between the
final two we're going to be asking our
special panel of our conservative
voters to try and get their sense on the
final two looking forward to speaking to
you
later on and we'll also have some top
guests for you including the former
conservative party leader and liz trust
supporter in duncan smith
the environment minister victoria
apprentice from the rishi sunak camp
plus will also see what labour makes of
it all with the party's deputy leader
angela rainer plus much more besides on
the take
[Music]
so and then there were two either rishi
sunak or liz trust will be the next
prime minister of the united kingdom
conservative mps decided to eliminate
penny morden in the final ballot earlier
and now of course it is over to the
members they will decide who takes over
on september 5th from boris johnson what
he said has to live to baby as he signed
off from his final prime minister's
questions in classic boris johnson style
well let's crack on shall we and start
with a quick recap of another
extraordinary day
therefore rishi sunak and liz trust will
be the candidates going forward to a
final ballast of conservative party
members thank you very much
[Music]
well there it is the result it was going
to be rishi sunak and liz truss who will
go through to the final stage of the
contest the two candidates and tory
party members are now going to vote on
who to be the next prime minister
[Applause]
[Music]
the question now for our members is who
is the best person to defeat kierstama
in the labour party at the next election
i believe i'm the only candidate who can
do that i'm the person who can go into
number 10 i can hit the ground running
and i can get things done and i think
that's what colleagues have voted for
and that's what i now want to take to
conservative members around the country
this is because you're right you say
last week i i told the house that this
was possibly the last week was possibly
my last pmq's this
week mr speaker probably certainly i
will be
my last pmq's from this dispatch box uh
or any other this bad boss
i'm not following this thing
particularly closely but my
my my my impression my impression is
that there's been a quite a lot of
debate already does the prime minister
agree with his former chancellor that
plans put forward by the other
candidates are in his words i've got
them here nothing more than the fantasy
economics of unfunded spending promises
mr speaker they know all about fantasy
economics he's just a great pointless
human bollard mr speaker that's what he
is
i think the message coming out of this
leadership contest is pretty clear they
got us into this mess and they've no
idea how to get us out of it hasta la
vista
baby
[Applause]
do you support theresa may at the end
there uh reluctantly standing up no
applause well we're going to speak to uh
conservatives backing each of the two
contenders uh this evening uh to start
with we're going to talk to you soon act
supporter and that is victoria
apprentice the environment minister uh
thank you so much for being uh with us
hello sophie you're gonna miss boris
johnson i saw you laughing along to that
and one time he was on form today he
really was um
he is a great performer
in the commons he's he's a great he's
been a great performer in the country
too and i think we will all remember him
with a certain amount of affection
and i want to talk to you about uh rishi
sunak who of course you are backing it
feels like until now he's been the front
runner you know he's been comfortably
ahead with the mps but now of course it
goes to conservative party members and
it's a bit of a different story isn't it
according to all of the polling liz
trust is ahead when it comes to the
members voting well the polling is i
think very difficult to read because of
course nobody knows who our members are
or where our members are so they're a
notoriously difficult bunch to identify
and then
manage to pull 800 of them it's quite
easy yes but that that's not really a
great poll size i i think i think it's
very hard to tell who's who starts
foremost in the members minds they've
got time to make up their minds
they're quite a sophisticated electorate
they've done this several times before
in recent years they've done it quite a
lot i'm meeting with my members in my
constituency tomorrow evening to chat
through the pluses and minuses of both
candidates and i suspect mps up and down
the country will be doing that at the
same time it feels like even rishi sunak
himself admits that he's the underdog he
said do we start from behind yes we do
in a video released on twitter we
certainly did a few weeks ago i think it
was not envisaged that our campaign
would have gone as well as it has
so i i think rishi is right to recognize
that we've made real progress over the
last few weeks i think he's performed
very well
both in the private hustings that we've
had in parliament and we've had loads of
those and also in in the more public
telly hustings
so i think
so far my perspective is we're running a
good campaign
rishi's real values of decency honesty
hard work
real ability and focus on the evidence
are coming through and i think our
members will notice that um it's
interesting isn't it the tone of the
leadership campaign you know we heard
kissed armor there just plucking uh what
the candidates are saying about each
other and throwing them straight back at
boris johnson does the prime minister
agree with rishi sunak the plans put
forward by his rivals are nothing more
than the fantasy economics of unfunded
spending promises i mean it's not
helpful is it this kind of thing from
well i think we've always been a really
broad church in the conservative party
and i think growing up debate about
policy is fine actually
economics well it's it was a debate and
and rishi was getting his point across
i think what has been less helpful is
the very
nasty sort of personal smearing that
that seems to have gone on but i i never
know how much of that is real and how
much is made up but i think what's very
important from our point of view is that
we are here to run a positive campaign
we're going to be telling
our voting public why rishi would make a
really good prime minister and all about
his good qualities and i think that's
the way to do it you say you want to run
a positive campaign uh rasheed simax
also tweeted to say today in in the
video who is the best person to beat
kirstama and the labour party at the
next election i believe i am the only
candidate who can do that so do you
think liz trust could win in an election
i think rishi
is the best candidate for winning an
election and that's why i'm backing him
of course he's the only candidate well
he's running for leader it's perfectly
proper for him to think and believe in
himself and i think that's the right way
to be
i have a lot of respect for liz too in
fact i have a lot of respect to all of
those candidates that put themselves
forward for the leadership it's a really
brave thing to do and golly politics is
brutal i walked through the lobby with
penny mordent almost immediately after
she she came third today and she was
there in public with all her colleagues
most of whom had voted for other people
and it it's a it's a funny old world
yeah it certainly is uh with you know it
does feel like it's moving at breakneck
speed at the minute
uh as well and i've been doing some
interviews as well with people earlier
and two other people who backed uh rishi
sunik were talking about liz truss's uh
policy agenda she says she wants a bold
new economic policy and both liam fox
and mark harper said to me that look if
she strays too far from the 2019
manifesto that of course you were
elected on then maybe it's right start
looking at a new mandate i.e another
election i'm really not keen on having
another election i think it's very
important that we have a period of
stability and calm now we've had a heck
of a time since the 2019 election we've
obviously had the covered pandemic we've
got war in europe now we are now facing
some really big challenges in my own
brief with cost of living and the cost
of food for example we got news on
inflation today
i really want a period of calm quiet
careful evidence-led government delivery
focused just making sure that we we get
our policies out there we we perform in
a way that people need us to do and we
give people help where they need us so
not straying too far from the last
manifesto well we were elected on a
manifesto we haven't really had much of
a chance to put many of those policies
into action because of the pandemic and
then the war so it is really important i
think that we come back together as a
party and i felt that today in pmq's i
felt as we said goodbye to boris in the
chamber i felt real unity and
and sort of a sense of purpose back in
the party
almost when we won that election and we
were elected on that manifesto so i
think it's important
that we do
get on with the business of governing
okay thank you very much indeed victoria
apprentice uh there well the place that
both rishi sunig and liz trust of course
want to end up on the 5th of september
is number 10 downing street so let's go
there shall we because our chief
political
correspondent john craig is there with
us now he's in a few of these contests
or down the years john put it into
context for us there's been lots of
discussion hasn't there about how nasty
this fight has been do we all need to
realize that this is always how politics
is or do you think it is actually quite
bitter this year
skullduggery black arts uh dirty tricks
they're nothing new i think perhaps some
politicians a bit more woke and
sensitive than they used to be in 1990
which is the first tory leadership i
election i covered where after margaret
thatcher was toppled
john major famously retreated to his
huntington constituency claiming that a
wisdom tooth operation had left him in
great pain and that prevented him from
endorsing margaret thatcher now he wrote
later revealed in his memoirs that not
only that um he uh he not only did he
sign a nomination paper for margaret
thatcher had she gone into the second
round he actually put gave geoffrey
archer's driver who was taking them back
to london uh his own nomination papers
and of course he entered the race and
saw off uh michael hesseltine and uh and
uh and uh douglas heard then in
1995 when mr major was challenged by uh
john redwood i remember being in the
garden for his put up or shut up news
conference um michael portillo professed
loyalty to john major at the same time
he was having 40 phone lines put in at a
house in lord north street the days
before mobile phones were as commonplace
as they are now
i'm planning to enter the second round
incidentally it was the same house in
north lord north street that liz trust
is using this time then in 2005 um david
davis this week has been complaining
about what he calls relocating of votes
well that's a bit rich many would say
because in 2005 it was claimed with some
authority that um david cameron's team
led by george osborne lent david davis
votes because mr cameron didn't want to
face liam fox because he regarded him as
a better performer in hustings i have to
say though the most
blatant flagrant act of treachery we've
seen i think in any of the last few
elections got to be michael gove
stabbing boris johnson in the front in
2016.
this week of course um
boris johnson got his two weeks ago
boris johnson's got his revenge sacking
mr go from the cabinet mr gove has now
been sacked uh from his cabinet job by
the last three conservative prime
ministers so he's paid the price but now
it's nothing new come on get over it
absolutely brilliant john thank you so
much for the little uh trip down memory
lane uh journey through the skullduggery
of these contests john craver in downing
street
now today liz trust eased penny mordant
out of the contest and moved into second
place with 113 votes from conservative
mps the former leader in duncan smith
has been one of the foreign secretary's
biggest supporters throughout the
campaign i caught up with him a bit
earlier in central lobby and started by
asking if it was always going to end up
being rishi sunak versus liz truss
it was always a tough fight between the
three of them and penny she did very
well
but yeah i always felt that liz would
get into the final round i didn't think
she had to win it but she needed to get
into the final round and now is she the
front runner i mean if you look at the
you go polling if you look at the con
home polling she's more popular with
members
i think that's the case
i think what's happened over the last
few weeks as she's been able to come out
from just being a government person
suddenly being herself
and i thought the last debate that they
had on the sunday night where she really
went for the chancellor and took him on
showed she's got steel she's got real
metal and she knows what she's doing and
i think there's a sense
now like some of the membership too that
they are concerned about the way boris
was dispatched and they're also worried
about those that did it so there's an
element of that in there as well so
rishi sunak you think that well yeah i
mean it's up to wishing how he runs his
campaign and uh i like rishi a lot but i
think liz
stayed in post did her job uh is a lot
i've had lots of comments back from my
association um and didn't abandon it in
the time of a war so there are there but
lots of people wanted boris out so i
mean you get a mix of it but i do sense
a certain amount of
concern about the way boris left i mean
that feels to be like quite a criticism
of rishi sooner that he abandoned at the
time of a war you talk about ukraine
well i'm only relating what they said i
don't say that's the killing thing i
think you know the fact is they'll be
judged on their economic policy and what
they think about the ukraine war about
china is going to be a big issue too
you know how do you deal with china
should we be doing what the treasury
want economic trade deals or not all
this stuff will be in the mix but you
know
members will make their decision about
who they thought did the right thing
and we'll see how that goes but i do
think liz has got a connection now with
the membership we'll talk about the
members but should we also be talking
about the electorate because look this
is you know not just a contest to be
concept party leader but also prime
minister and rishi sunak is more popular
than liz trust if you look at the polls
of the general public and also boris
johnson might be popular with the
membership but
we're calling with the general public
experience it goes to the wider public
most of the wider public know one or two
people in government reasonably well
chancellor always well the prime
minister as well she's a foreign
secretary she is she's not like a lowly
back venture the word is foreign
secretary which means she's away from
the country a lot and doesn't get out
into the country as much as some of the
others
so what you'll see now over the
campaigns that goes out to the country
is more and more people who are not
members will watch
see what's going on get to know who
people are already when it first started
she was well below but she's come up a
long way
and originally the members were in favor
of others but now they're in favor of
her so you can see that
exposure on these sort of names etc does
help people get to know who they are she
hasn't done a single broadcast interview
do you think that needs to change
i think she's right not to have done
broadcast this is about the members now
we're through with the members now
she'll do broadcast interviews because
she's going to the country so that's
important not to do too many too early
but to do them on the right time and
debates i think well there'll be debates
i'm sure but also i guess
you'll be seeing her on things like this
yeah um
there's been the tone of the debate i
want to talk to you about a bit because
obviously the conservative party needs
to uh survive afterwards uh kia stammer
at prime minister's questions
effectively just reading out a list of
things that candidates have said
including liz trust about richie's sunax
economic
record are you worried that she's gone
in studs up against the chancellor
no not really again i may sound
complacent about it but every leadership
campaign i've either been involved when
i've been seven run two one one so i
know that almost all of them end up
being quite fierce
because this is the biggest and most
important job in britain and it's also
going to decide whether we will lose the
next election we'll be the person in
charge so there's going to be edge
there's going to be tightness it's not
like labor versus conservative where
there's a really big gap this is really
about two conservatives who kind of
agree in general terms about what should
happen but pace of change you know when
should tax cuts come in how much should
they be what you do with levies all
these things are debates in detail and
that's what's going on there is a big
difference between rishi sunax economic
plan and liz truss's economic plan she's
criticized the chancellor's economic
plan you have as well you've talked
about its failure to get inflation under
control for example as well so there is
a big choice in the economy there is
going to be a choice and choice is
important because we have two views
about where we are and two views about
where we need to get to so i would think
all candidates want to get us to a place
where we have growth the question is do
you think it should happen now or do you
think you want to put it on my answer is
liz is right we have the headroom to do
these redactions in tax it's the only
way we can help those on low income you
know people paying marginal rates of tax
that have now been frozen people that
are on low income tax the bottom rate
they're all suffering risky sooner says
it's fantasy economics well
i've heard
people say to ronald reagan i remember
that he was practicing voodoo economics
but he turned america around i remember
people saying about margaret thatcher
that she didn't understand economics and
that her plan to get the economy grain
wouldn't work
and she won endless elections for two
things trust but patronizing i think you
be careful what you say when you say to
somebody it's it's fantastic land it's
not fantasy land this is what people
want this is what they need we cannot we
simply cannot afford
i'm sorry we cannot afford to have
high taxes and
high interest rates we will crush the
economy so growth is critical this is
where i disagree with the treasury
orthodoxy treasury has been wrong on so
many occasions when it looks ahead into
the future it seems to have an inability
to understand what people need
politicians are there to do that liz is
right we need to keep growth going we
need to get the burdens down on people
so they can get through this spike
in cost of living
in doug and smith they're one of the
most vocal uh supporters of uh
liz trust a little bit late later we're
going to get labour's take on all this
uh with the party's deputy leader angela
rainer but just before we do let's speak
to our deputy political editor sam coats
shall we um so what i i guess most
people want to know is right we've got
the final two now who is starting the
next phase of the race out in front
well
the answer to that question hurts your
head because through so many rounds of
mp voting all five rounds rishi sunak
was the man to be he had the highest
number of mps in the tally
um but now everything has changed and
liz trust facing rishi sunat will the
members polling suggest that according
to the polling done by yougov of tory
members on monday and tuesday rishi
tsunak would lose to liz trust by a
margin of 54 to 35 so a big difference
almost a double-digit difference between
the two candidates suggesting at this
stage that rishi sunat really has a
fight on his hands quite interesting
tonight that he's put out this video uh
saying that he uh is behind in this race
that's quite an admission given where he
was coming from uh just before so i
think that's why both candidates are
going to go big on the differences
between them big on the differences
between them does that mean
in other words that we're going to see a
pretty
feisty fiery bitter debate as we've been
saying all along i think this is going
to come down to three areas personality
tax and brexit and i'd expect pretty
combustible uh clashes between the two
including on the new uh sky news debate
on august thursday august the fourth at
eight o'clock with k burley but all the
way through uh the debate between those
two because
richie's sunak's job is not only to say
that he would beat kirsten but his
version of the kind of change that the
country needs is to project the image of
somebody who's going to return a bit of
stability and a bit of integrity to the
way that government is run liz truss's
pitch is that you need something of a
big bang tax cuts doesn't matter so much
if we borrow a bit more in the short
term boldness again on brexit being
another part of her solution now it has
to be said at this point of cost of
living crisis uh risk taking with liz
trust might have uh might ward off some
of the membership but her tax cutting
vision might prove attractive a calmer
more sensible government might attract
some of the conservative membership but
perhaps there aren't enough solutions to
people's everyday everyday problems uh
for others so i think there's all to
play for in this race it remains so
complicated so there's been so many
twists and turns to this point uh that
we just don't know quite where it's
going to end up in early september yeah
this is it's been so unpredictable
hasn't it and i feel like there may be
some twists to come as we roll through
the summer sam thank you very much for
your analysis we'll have more from sam
later on the programme
now the prospect of the former
chancellor at rishi sunak and the
current foreign secretary spending the
next six weeks tearing chunks out of
each other over the government's record
must seem quite appealing to the labour
party the opposition now has consistent
leads in the polls soon the leader
leader kirstama is going to have a new
opposite number to face at the next
election well i spoke to the deputy
leader angela reyna a little earlier i
started by asking her who should be more
worried about fighting at an election
so who would you be most worried about
fighting a general election rishi sunac
or los trust neither of them they've
both been stooges in boris johnson's
government they've both voted for the
tax hikes that people have seen they
both created this cost of living crisis
and propped up a prime minister that is
engulfed in sleaze lies and partying
while people are in lockdown so i would
relish the thought of going head-to-head
with either one of them i think they're
both just as complicit this is the same
continuation of what has happened in
downing street and what's been happening
with this government for a long time now
and it shows they've got no new ideas
and they've not got the future of the
country at hand well i guess you know
rishi sunak would say that he resigned
from boris johnson's government liz
trust would say that she's promising a
different economic policy it's not
completely continuous continuity boris
isn't it well it'll be interesting to
see how they try and move away from that
over the summer but you know roshi sunak
was the chancellor who did put the tax
heights up and liz trust did support it
and did vote for it at the time and you
know
she did stay in the government for a
very long time knowing full well he was
in number 11. in fact my part his
neighbours were having a party i think
i'd have known about it in fact he was
fined himself for a fixed penalty notice
i think they're both just as disastrous
and there is continuation of the same
old maybe not boris johnson but the same
old conservative party and what they've
been trying to get away with so you say
you wouldn't be frightened about
fighting either them an election you
told lbc that boris johnson had a magic
where he was able to get through to the
public so do you think he was more of an
electoral threat for labour than i was
with these two well he clearly was
because in 2019 you know labour suffered
a significant defeat and that was
because boris johnson promised the
electorate something and he did have
something that the electorate connected
to do you think they probably had
something in the election no and this is
the problem the problem what boris
johnson did is he broke that trust with
the electorate after getting that
80-seat majority he broke the trust the
two now propped him up after the public
had seen that boris johnson had
squandered that victory that he had lied
to the british public put taxes up not
dealt with the issues that they're
facing at moment with a cost of living
crisis and the two contenders now we're
part of that government and they don't
have that connection with the public i
don't believe and i think the public
have had enough of the conservative
party because they've seen even in this
leadership contest they've been fighting
each other and trying to distance
themselves from decisions that they've
been part of if they do distance
themselves from the last uh government
promise a new agenda do you think that
actually they have a mandate to carry it
out or do you think they should re-seek
a mandate through an election i think
they should re-seek a mandate i think
the general public are very angry we saw
that with the by-election results
recently the public are very angry with
the conservative party the problem
started with when boris johnson broke
the trust with the british people and
then because of people like rishi and
liz who propped him up in the cabinet
allowed that to continue the rot to
continue it has now stayed in the whole
of the conservative party so i don't
actually think that they would get a
mandate from the british public now
because they've failed so spectacularly
in doing what the british public asks
them to do whatever happens
the conservative party is either about
to elect the first ever non-white prime
minister or the third female prime
minister all of whom have been
conservative
that's a bit embarrassing for the labour
party isn't it well we will get there
you know we have got our leader at the
moment i'm the deputy i've heard it i'm
the time
i'm the deputy um leader of our party
which means if we get into government
i'll be the deputy prime minister
working class girl from the north same
as the prime minister though is it oh it
matters a lot and it will make a big
difference and i think you know the
labour party come the next leadership
election i'm pretty certain we've got
some magnificent talent in our party and
i think that we'll be able to showcase
that come the next leadership election
but either we've got a bit they mustn't
it well i think the party have done
better than you i think the equality
diversity diversity matters sure
diversity matters in terms of where
people are from et cetera but diversity
in terms of ideas matters as well and at
the moment we're getting the same old
policies and the same old ideas and the
same old sleaze from the conservatives
at the moment they haven't addressed the
issues that people are facing like the
cost of living actually most people will
say yes diversity matters and it's great
however if you're offering the same
things and you're not actually making a
difference to my life in the way i want
them to that matters more and i think we
can show that the labour party has
changed since mainly and care took over
and that we can show that we've got a
program that can get us into government
and change people's lives for the better
you touched a bit about your own
background uh there and you know you
grew up in stockport you were a carer
for your mum you had a baby at 16. you
know it is quite a different path from
you know the sort of well-trodden ppe
oxford do you think that people
underestimate you sometimes in
parliament people who have
underestimated underestimated me all my
life if i'm honest you know and i
remember the stigma that i faced when i
was a young mum at 16 and it still burns
now and that's why i'm so passionate
about giving people opportunity and not
um you know some of the rhetoric that
we've heard from conservative ministers
around will just work a little bit
harder the problem with you being on low
pays you just need to get a better job
actually i find that quite offensive
because when i was a low-paid worker i
was a casual worker zero-hour contract
care worker and i was a young mum i
struggled then and it was nowhere near
as bad as the cost of living for those
people today and it's not about them not
wanting to work harder i think it's the
conservative party are really out of
touch with how people are really
struggling today people in work are
really struggling and are frightened
about what's going to happen come
october when it's winter and their bills
go up again and their cost of living and
their food prices are going up people
are really struggling and not hearing
from the conservatives what they're
going to do to challenge that what kind
of stigma you mentioned in the stigma
that you faced oh it's just like oh she
speaks with an access accent she must be
thick i'll probably get that again after
being on your show unfortunately um i'm
working class so therefore you know
we're not as good if you know if a posh
guy from a private school walks in the
room he automatically gains respect oh
he's got a status if i walk in a room i
have to earn the respect because people
look at me and look at me differently
and and that's how society is
unfortunately it's not unique for me
many women and many working class people
face those challenges as well many
people from uh you know many people of
color face the same level of
discrimination as well and it is a
product of society unfortunately and
we've got to change that that's why i
won't change the way i speak that's why
i talk about my background is because we
can do better and actually the general
public when they see more of that and
they see people in positions of power
being making a difference and really
holding their own then it changes that
perception i was quite struck when you
went toe-to-toe with donald trump
recently at deputy prime minister's
questions and he said she talks about
working people where was the right
honourable lady when the comrades were
on the picket line last thursday she was
at the glenborn music festival sipping
champagne and listening to opera
do you think that's a kind of snobbery
in itself well it is a snobbery in
itself actually you know i've always
fought for workers all my life and
everyone knows that my record is very
clear on that and i think the government
have really failed to tackle some of the
issues they're in power and have really
failed to tackle the issues that we face
at the moment with endemic low pay for
workers of course they're angry and they
have my full support with that but the
idea that a working class person can't
go to the opera when actually i was
there to visit a working-class
friend of mine who plays violin at the
opera and has played violin there for 36
years and was proud to be there i think
that shows how out of touch is actually
working-class people can enjoy opera and
should be able to go there and in fact
the tickets to go to the opera were a
lot cheaper than the tickets to go to
glastonbury but hey i wonder whether i'd
have got the same stigma if i'd have
been seen raving it at glastonbury um
briefly on that same uh outing
dominic rob winked right i think
actually might be to show the um
the photo of him winking now he i asked
him about this
i asked him about this he said he wasn't
winking at you he was winking in route
murray do you believe him i think he's
winking at himself i think he thought he
did a really good job it was really
weird me and rachel looked to each other
and said that was weird it was just a
very weird thing to do
and just finally now i know i'm going to
ask this question you're going to be
studiously lord kirsten you're going to
say that he is the person you want to
see as the next prime minister so we can
just take that as a given but do you
think you've got what it takes to be
prime minister oh do you know i say this
all the time when originally i used to
think there's no way that i could be
prime minister of this country you know
that the fact that i got into parliament
it's such an honor to represent my
constituency of rational line but since
boris johnson has done it i thought he
set the bar so low that i actually think
even terry from the local pub could do a
better job than what boris johnson has
done but actually we need standards in
public life
what's
yes i think i could do it now i think i
could and actually i think it's really
important that um kids from my
background do have that aspiration and
think you know what you can do it and i
was guilty of thinking i couldn't do it
because for all of the reasons i think
there's always someone better than
myself and actually i think on your show
speaking to people from my background i
should say you could do whatever you
want because you'll put your mind to it
quite like fancy
i think it would be really don and you
know if i can't go to the opera then god
help me if i became prime minister okay
thank you uh very much angela rainer
there
well there you go straight answer she
thinks that she could do it to become
prime minister a little later tonight
we're gonna have a new edition of the
sky news daily podcast with neil
patterson which you can subscribe to by
scanning the qr code on the screen now
and neil and deputy political editor sam
coats are going to have all the reaction
from westminster and they'll look at
what both liz truss and rishi sunak
stand stanford so really interesting
podcast today you can subscribe to it
for free wherever you get your podcasts
well a pretty busy day in westminster
i'm really looking forward to seeing
what our viewers panel uh make of it all
who do they want to win a conservative
voter's panel do they want rishi sunak
or do they want this
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the boat
hello welcome back live to westminster
you're watching the take on another
really big day in politics we now of
course know it is gonna be rishi sunak
versus liz truss who can battle it out
to be the next conservative party leader
and of course the next prime minister
too now it's up to party members to
decide we're gonna have a new pm by
september the fifth so i'm excited to
find out what our panel of conservative
voters make of the two candidates now i
have to say because i would be wondering
this if i was watching at home we have
got an all-male panel tonight it was not
supposed to be this way our female
panelist in cumbria had her broadband
drop out so i think that says it all
perhaps when it comes to
rural broadband uh but we have a
fantastic panel for you i'm excited to
know everyone's thoughts on the last two
people now i want to go to john first
john commerford who is in kent now john
i want to talk to you because the last
time we spoke you said you've always
voted conservative your whole life but
you're so disillusioned with boris
johnson that you can bring yourself to
vote for him do you feel the same about
liz trust and rishi sunak all
differently
i think that there was
an opportunity that has been lost
because
british
and this trust
have kept one of the constant power
whatever demeanors he's done over over
the extended
okay what did you make
sorry apologies and what did you make of
boris johnson's last prime minister's
questions
uh
it was to me like an end of term counter
uh thank you uh very much uh john really
interesting uh to talk today well let's
go to roy shall we uh roy roya from kent
you had a few choice words about rishi
sunak when my producer spoke to you
earlier what do you make of the two
candidates still in it
um
well i think the absolute requirement
for anybody who aspires to be um
to have an office uh in in in government
is to be loyal to that government or to
be loyal to that state certainly and i
think
um rishi sunax choosing to uh apply
and in fact hold a green card
left a very very sour taste in my mouth
i i'm not sure where his
loyalties would lie
in respect of great britain should he be
elected
um you know he was on maneuvers against
boris johnson and fair enough that's
that's politics um but i think the green
card issue was the main thing that
he's just lost it for me i i have
absolutely no respect for him anymore as
a result of that
liz troth
she was
really not much in my mind um
over the last few years i think
um in the foreign office she did quite
well and i i think on on the whole
ukrainian um issue
she um showed a different side to her
character so i'm interested to see what
more she can bring but as far as rishi
it's it's either liz or none at all for
me
wow there you go so some pretty uh start
views about the two people left uh in it
let's bring in vic daniels at shall we
joining us from london what do you make
of the final two
i think they're both jason counters
both were experienced
um i'm not particularly a russian fan
um i didn't like the way he resigned in
a fairly optimistic way a couple of
weeks ago
i don't like the fact that he's risen
taxes uh uh increased taxation
uh 15 times
um and i also think that unlike andrew
lorena
um he's not real he's too rich and i
don't think he can relate to a man
having said that
i'd probably vote for him if i had a
vote
because i think um he's had experience
as chancellor that experience will be
very relevant
because the next two years it's all
going to be about fiscal
and finance
um and uh i think that um
uh
i just i just think that you know
he's a man with the right experience
and um
reluctantly i'd hold on i'd vote for him
you mentioned the angela rainer angela
there and i know that you probably heard
the interior just did with her as your
conservative voter but what do you make
of her as a politician do you think she
could tempt you to switch over or do you
think she's a formidable opponent
look i'm an east end boy so i can relate
to angela rainer i think that you know
she's passionate she's got fire and
she's real i don't agree with her
political views but i totally respect
her as an individual
and uh it would be it would be great for
this country in some ways if she was
given that opportunity that's really
interesting so you think she'd be a more
formidable opponent than kirsten for the
conservatives then
100
interesting interesting stuff right
let's bring in paul now shall we paul
blom uh from uh north west uh london uh
now you were tom tugan hat fan weren't
you so we were a bit disappointed to see
him not go through
yes i was very much so um but i think he
actually ran a very poor uh campaign uh
in the leadership election
but interestingly i heard today that uh
chris bryant said that
uh tom tugman hat was the uh candidate
that laid but with most fear which i
thought was quite um
a good insight into perhaps the
candidates
and at the final two rishi sunak and liz
trust who do you find most appealing
well i've warned to rishi sooner really
um
i i tend to agree with his views on tax
i think he's been you know chancellor
doing the pandemic
so he he must know what's happening in
the economy and i kind of do go along
with him with his views on what we need
to do to try and help the cost of living
crisis that we're in
i'm not sure liz trustee's ideas are
really
going to help um and i i
i think richie sunic
probably has got a better insight into
what we should be doing having said that
i'm not sure
how the general electorate will consider
the she susan hanker as an authentic
character i think
liz trust is perhaps more relatable to
um to to the wider wider electorate in
the country i think interesting stuff
well let's bring in rob tyler shall we
are you joining us from bolton and rob i
thought you made quite an interesting
point uh when you spoke to my producer
earlier you said my heart is with trust
but my mind is with rishi what did you
mean by that
well um
i think that
when we look at
liz truss's
she's looking at really spending a way
forward
um and letting the when the debts take
the strain
whereas uh ricky is kind of in what
constraints
and and try and get herself out of our
financial situation before he looked
have any
uh any real
cuts and and helping for the for the
people um
for me that went forward
but
um
i would like to see the people get a
little bit and so maybe this would get
me that box
right now i'm going to ask all of you a
question okay and i would like to get
it's a straw poll obviously if you would
like to see rishi sunak uh win over list
trusts i would like you to raise your
hand so if you if you prefer issues to
liz trust
put your hand up now
right that's three out of our five and
if you are a liz trust fan
over rishi sunak put your hands up now
uh
two a reluctant second one i thought
just going up there right we got so it's
quite it's quite um it's quite split
isn't it um relatively easy evenly split
with that panel richie cena just
squeezing it um roy you were quite slow
to put up your hand i'm not sure if
that's uh because you know you were just
thinking about it or was there a bit of
reluctance
no it's just it's just a lag on the
internet oh no
try not to play too much out of it
sophie yeah
i thought you were just like weighing up
the options trying to work out what was
going on
okay and my final question my final
question trevor we had boris johnson's
last pmq's today if you think boris
johnson would be more likely to win an
election and should have stayed on as
leader
compared to the two that we've got now
put up your hands if you prefer to keep
boris johnson still there
there you go three of you would
and if you're pleased that boris
johnson's left and you think we might be
getting a clean start with rishi or liz
truss
raise your hand
so that's two again quite split really
interesting to talk really interesting
to talk and it does i think show how
everything is at all to play for just
you know a small straw poll of course uh
not anything uh scientific but really
interesting to hear at people's takes on
the battle between rishi cenac and liz
truss
you are watching the take we're live in
westminster for you at this evening up
next we're going to round up everything
we've just heard do a bit of end of term
analysis not just post match for end of
term
with uh sam coates so stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
you are watching the take we've had lots
of takes this evening after an
absolutely extraordinary period of
british politics so haven't been a final
end of term analysis with our deputy
political editor uh sam coats who joins
us now it's felt like we've had politics
on fast forward for the last few weeks
but worth taking a moment boris
johnson's final pmqs as a prime minister
now you know the two people who want to
take over that job and of course it's
worth reflecting you know they're not
going to be leading the conservative
party but prime minister that's right
and i have to say politics has been on
fast forward for the last few weeks but
in my view really since
september 2014 when there was a scottish
referendum and certainly since
june 2016 the brexit referendum big
questions about britain unsettled that's
one of the reasons behind the fact that
we've ended up changing prime minister
today now rishi sunak and liz trust are
going to give everything they have over
the next few weeks to try and succeed
boris johnson but i just thought it'd be
useful to try and fast forward six
months and imagine
at the end of it what that might look
like because the challenges that they
face are immense take just one energy
now we all know bills are going up
additional amounts on our bills to be
announced at the end of august even
before the end of the contest officials
are even talking about what's happening
if there's a cold winter and whether we
can all keep the lights on every day of
the week every week incredible to think
of but that's a consequence of uh the
situation that we're in then there is
inflation just today you had pay rises
of just under five percent for a lot of
public sector bodies you had inflation
of over nine percent and what does that
mean well that means industrial action
quite a lot of the different bodies
representing different bits of the
public sector saying that they're going
to go out on strike again that's going
to hit whichever of rishi sunak and liz
trust become prime minister and then
within months there are going to be
potentially some very difficult choices
around ukraine that has really got
bogged down it's so telling that this
isn't an issue that we're talking about
day in day out at the moment it's not
necessarily going the way that everyone
in the west would want how are people
going to deal with vladimir putin and
what he is doing in ukraine then we get
on to brexit and the northern ireland
protocol one of the biggest gambles liz
truss in favor of really facing down the
eu rishi soon a bit more cautious is
list trust willing to have a full-on
confrontation that could take us all the
way through to tariffs which will cost
the uk economy more if the confrontation
goes all the way to the wire and finally
this woman
nicolas sturgeon has promised a
referendum in
2023 so that's next year uh can she
follow through on that what will happen
with that those are the kind of things
that the new prime minister will have to
confront now boris johnson looked very
much to me in the commons chamber like
he didn't think that he should be going
it was a gritted teeth performance he
told his successor to look in the back
mirror uh at the people behind him and
stabbed him in the back uh he blamed the
treasury coded jab at rishi sunak he
thinks he should be staying the
interesting thing for conservative mps
is whether they start to agree with him
as the month go on yeah be interesting
to see how those two people managed to
cope with the
whole menu of big things that they need
to sort out that you just are taking us
through with their successor somewhere
in the background yeah i can imagine
he's not gonna be the easiest backseat
driver as well sam thank you very much
always good to hear your analysis
well that is it uh for the take normally
at this stage i say we're going to be
back next week but actually we won't
because it is now at summer recess and
that means a little break for the take
it's been an absolute pleasure
to launch the show here on wednesday
nights what a time in politics we are
having but we will be back when we know
of course how the leadership contest is
going it's going to be a really
interesting summer
thank you very much for watching we'll
be back in september looking forward to
it
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory who can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
[Music]
you